Mọi chuyển ngà sẽ gây lạc rốt ngày mục chi thống như một cho biết,
sợ sàng gặp chức tiếp người đồng cấp Mỹ Mắc Cô Rubio để thảo lợt về vấn đề u cua nè và quả hệ sông phương,
sông khẳng định, Mắc Cô và không thể đổi lập triân có lỗi về điều kiện, chấm giữ suốt của cua nè.
Phát biểu với Hạ Tien Ria, Novistii, của Ngà, Vì ngoài triân cho biết các,
nhiều biết đã được dở tổng thống, bởi vì mì phút Tien và người đồng cấp Mỹ đồ nên tròm tại thup định
á lắc Scà thẳng tảm năm 2020.
Chúng không phải mấy lắm, bất đất coi là giả trình, mắc Cô và Bảo Tòn trong đó ngà yêu cầu kia từ bỏ
ý định dành ra nhập tổ chức hiếp ước mất đạc tây dường nato và giúp quân coi bún tình,
mọi gà xan nhập gồm đồ nhét, Lu Ghanc, Khaeson và Giapurisia.
Ông là rốt cũng cạnh báo việc phương tay tịch thu hơn 200% tỷ ở rô tài sản cuo rằng
nhà bị đồng băng sẽ bất phải đắp trả mạnh mẽ.
Chức đó của gặp giữa 2 diện ngoài triân đã được lên kế hoạt, nhằm trình bình lỗi giống cho của gặp
lình lần 2, dự ông Putin và ông Trump tải đude a pest phục gà rì nhưng sau đó
lâu bệ bệnh nhất bất đồng lên quán để lạnh được bán.
Tổ thung Trump sau đó vàng bố lệ trường phạt linh a lần đầu tiên kệ thực hiện tại nhận.
Cung ngày 11 chiếc mấy một tổng thống uc quan nè vô đồ đi Miyaziraiski cho biết
kia đang phối hợp với liên mình châu Âu để hoàn tất gói xin phạt thứ 2 mới, nhằm bằng a
dự kiến hoàn tất trong vòng bụth hàng tối. Ông đề sất tổ xung các tổ chức,
càng nhìn ngã và thú lợi từ năng lượng vào giống xác tâm bất và nhìn mạnh uc quan nè sẽ trường phạt mỏ lời
hợp lá, bộ mại trình trang của ngà. Pháp đều cũng sẽ nên xí do gia khi nè của ta thông mề bột.
Ngà ra tăng tân công hà tần năng lượng uc quan nè, chiếc tính nhất bản người trên mạc và mất địa dự rau.